Natacha ednan la pérouse had no idea a
Preta Monge sandwich could kill her she
was allergic to sesame but allergens and
ingredients are not listed on individual
sandwiches the only warning is on the
shelves now pret says it will introduce
full labeling but not until next year
after a trial starting next month I went
to the inquest and I saw the impact the
Natasha's death has had on the family
and it's absolutely heartbreaking so on
a personal level I'm devastated
but the coroner asked for changing the
law the family of asked for changing the
law and I'm now making changes in pret
they'll make that change in the law
happen more quickly and probably
probably better we showed his statement
to Natasha's parents they say he's not
acting fast enough I would say to anyone
who has allergies serious allergies
always concerned about allergies in any
way I would say don't buy a sandwich or
go into a pet emoji because they're
still holding your life at risk right
now would you accept that you have been
exploiting a loophole aimed at small
businesses and you're a company that's
turning over close to 900 million pounds
last year what that looks like a huge
company but in fact is 500 duplications
so Natasha mama says if prep really was
a small business you could act quicker
they sell a certain number of sandwiches
a certain number of baguettes they make
a certain number of foods in their
kitchens it is not impossible for a
small kitchen that he knows are his
words it's a small kitchen so the amount
of sandwiches that they produce that
they can't put labels on those accurate
allergen labels is actually
inconceivable Preta Monge has been
forced to act to try and restore its
reputation but by exposing this loophole
in the law Natasha's death may change
the way food is labeled across the high
street Greg says it is reviewing its
policy on items made in store and the
government has promised to review the
law forcing others to follow safer food
shops maybe a legacy of Natasha's
needless avoidable death
Paul Kelso sky